welcome back to new rock stars new looks
from spider-man no way home show doc ock
trying to crush spider-man's head making
us wonder what is running through this
madman's mind like when i get dragged
into a surprise party my first thought
is not ever hmm let me turn to the
sweetest looking boy say hi peter and
then restage the mountain versus the
viper to implode his skull
what is going on this is rogue theory
the show where we pitch the wildest
series for the nerdy titles we love i'm
eric voss and going rogue with me today
is our own friendly neighborhood jessica
clemons
[Music]
and warping into our timeline from the
twitch dimension it's angelica trey hey
it's good to be back good to have you
back and finally our guy in the chair
especially at this exact moment it's
empty
man in the chain
it's me everybody i thought you're
saying more stupid things on your screen
yet again hello i love you all
and we love you emt especially knowing
that right before you taped your clear
branches through your neighborhood
because there's a crazy nor'easter in
the northeast
it actually wasn't it was literally a
whole tree and i couldn't move it so
it's it's literally still in the middle
of the road i feel like stay safe out
there careful because those branches
coming from florida i'm always afraid to
touch branches because they're connected
to power lines that they've tripped on
it's it's a scary time so just say very
scary yeah um all right well we're going
to talk about doc ock and spider-man no
way home we got some new set photos from
empire magazine showing otto octavius
doc ock battling with spider-man using
the classic maneuver of constricting him
with his tentacle arms and trying to
crush his head between this and alfred
molina's happy hi peter lying in the
trailer what exactly is going through
this guy's head like since getting
warped into this reality is he still
pursuing that agenda of completing his
fusion reaction is he just trying to
kill anything that looks like spider-man
is he trying to get home or does he like
it better in the mcu what do you guys
think i feel like he wasn't ready for
the scale of things and he's just going
after anything that resembles spider-man
and
yeah i'd imagine he's not i don't think
he's ready to venture through any sort
of multiverse but but who knows you know
maybe he's full of surprises yeah do we
do we think that he knows that he has
gone into another dimension yet or does
he still think he's in the same version
of new york city that he left maybe he's
just confused and he thinks there's a
copycat or something
copycat spidey who is this grab his head
it's like you're not toby mcguire i like
the rainy films better
normal child that he's trying to kill in
a costume exactly it's like it's not
pizza time
it's not halloween yet what are you
doing
yeah because like we got to remember in
that moment during the fusion reaction
yes he was pissed off at peter but only
because peter was meddling with his plan
to like resurrect his science experiment
uh and yeah he did capture mary jane but
it was really just to kind of lure in
peter parker he wasn't that homicidal i
guess you could say he kind of was that
whole train battle he was straight up
trying to kill
of keeping the sun in the palm of his
hand does he care anymore about having
the sun in the palm of his hand is he
just like a straight up i'm gonna kill
anything that's red blue and whippy all
over i think
that yeah oh yeah i think so i think
that doc ock in his timeline or his
universe has succeeded in killing peter
parker to be
to continue building his reaction his
fusion reaction and then when that spell
happens and they drop into the mcu or
what we call our peter parker's timeline
they come in and they see all of the
stuff on the news that are like peter
parker spider-man peter parker
spider-man and he's like
i just killed this guy i have to go kill
him again and so he's going to kill this
peter parker just out of like i need to
kill peter parker he's going to ruin and
foil my plans so he could be confused
ultimately what angelica says but i
think it'd be fun to see him be like i
just killed this guy how is he still
alive and just because there if there's
multiple timelines multiple branches
there could be a timeline where this doc
ock did successfully kill peter parker
and it'd be sad but i do like the idea
of a dead peter parker um i think he
brings you closer i like the idea of a
dead boy jessica is the sixth member of
the sinister six yeah i think
it's confirmed not that i want more than
to murder this child but
this young young boy
uh i hope tom holland's not watching
this i'm a big fan and i would never
wish death upon you but in this series i
need it um i need to feel that
connection that we did get in in um in
the the animated spider-man um that we
did see it's like when he died we were
like we didn't even get to see that
peter parker for long but just because
he died it was like oh damn this is
emotional and i'm attached so i think
still having a dead peter parker in a
timeline is a good idea
yeah i think what's like we have to
remember that this is why i'm so
obsessed with this question when we
watch the no way home trailer again and
again and we see all these uh you know
teases come out all these theories like
i think we forget that these are all
like adult brilliant scientist
characters who left a story where they
were in charge of the agenda uh and they
aren't just like toys we get to play
with again who are dropped into our
marvel cinematic universe like alfred
molina is an experienced stage actor he
has to play some objective in this movie
he's not just here just so we can have
doc ock again like he has a mission that
he is on
and you gotta imagine he's now in a
universe that's presumably gonna have uh
willem dafoe norman osborne
as alfred molina uh uh doc as otto
octavius he had a deal begrudgingly with
um with harry osborne who just carried
on the ozcorp legacy of funding his
experiments but presumably knew who
willem dafoe norman osborne was so if he
gets to see him again he now views him
as like a potential ally and what his
technological ambitions were so are they
working together to attack this bridge
in this moment
are they rivals or are they just like
two wrestlers who ended up end up in the
same ring who are like all right you and
me tag team let's go brother they have
to be working together when doc ock be
the lead or well if we're going
depends on which centers or sticks we're
going with but i thought doc ock was
gonna be the leader of this bunch of
hooligans
um
maybe
i i assumed he's also empty
empty get in here maybe they're just
okay
yeah see i think that
i think the main motivation for all of
these people could be the the main
motivator for most bad guys uh
especially in real life money i think
that there's probably a huge bounty on
this peter parker's head and we have you
know your your uh your lizards your your
doc ox who wants to make a have the sun
in his hand have the whole sun in his
hand um and you know all those people
and then you have norman osborne
basically funding this this whole thing
it's like we need to kill this man and i
think what's going to make this movie
super unique is that i'm of the mind
that peter parker goes to this weird
amalgam universe where
the
rainy spider-man the
web spider-man and elements from his
world are mashed up together
into this one world and i think that
every time like a spider-man villain
sees peter they see his version like the
version that they're familiar with yeah
and they're like all right so like yeah
like that's so dark oxy toby maguire is
like i'm gonna get you and get that
money because uh i don't like you anyway
so we're back in the uh the mt theory of
it's all a side playground it's not the
mcu don't worry kiddos people can get
hurt and die with no effect on our main
mcu continuity
yeah as i think that the whole peter
parker um being out of the mcu that
whole drama that we all the trauma that
we all went through with uh sony and
marvel not having
go seeing eye to eye
i think that elements of that are still
here i think that's spider-man will not
stay in the mcu
forever because sony still owns
spider-man like even though it feels
like spider-man's in the mcu forever
that's not necessarily true and i think
that right now sony is making this weird
playground that spider-man will end up
playing in with you know that past you
know sony spider-man history already
intact
i'm saying there is a toby but the world
that they're in mashes up like the past
of like toby and andrew together with
peter's past to make this weird like
this is the the one and only uh
spider-man we're smooshing all their
souls together essentially and like
pushing the souls of their universes
together to make this weird new universe
is where all the movies are canon now
but yeah the main motivator i think for
doc ock here is just money i think that
there he wants to fund his experiments
to you know for the reason why he has
those arms to mess with the sun i think
that's still there and i think that all
these people are desperate and they're
just want to kill peter parker for the
cash see i don't think it's got to be
more than money though because money was
an easy thing for doc to get in the
first movie he robbed a bank joel mchale
was like sure take all my money like i
think that's an easy thing for him to
get his hands on he only got money in
pursuit of rebuilding his fusion tech
experiment see i think like in that
moment he's freaked out and peter is the
first recognizable thing in this altered
world so he's like kid tell me where i
am tell me where i am
what universe is this and then peter
goes oh you're in the wrong universe and
then he just throws up his arms
[Laughter]
is it still canon and are we still
keeping in mind that at the end of that
peter that doc ock he straight up was
just like controlled by his tentacles
and he was like you listen to me now so
he changed himself he like you listen to
me now so he changed who he was so i'm
also like are we gonna get that in this
movie where he's gonna come back to who
he once was or are we getting the only
solely crazy doc that's controlled by
his tentacles
it depends when during that boathouse
battle he gets sucked in during because
is it before peter parker electrocutes
him and he goes
and that kind of zaps the neural chip in
his spinal cord if it's before that the
arms are still in charge and he's still
pretty evil if it's after that you know
alfred molina has been able to like
summon up the balls to be like listen to
me now and then he's more in charge yeah
i think it's gonna be before i think i'm
gonna get more so we there we have to
electrocute him again to get his senses
back which could
do jamie foxx could do jamie foxx
he's like what am i doing here i'm going
crazy i need my children i need my wife
your wife is still dead she's still dead
he comes back to that let's flip the
switch okay so that's it take the wheel
arms i'm pissed off again
um i i wonder i think mt you're on to
something i don't know if it's gonna be
a completely separate pocket reality i
still think it's gonna be the mcu
because sony wants it to be mcu they
want it to be universe where doctor
strange and wong and iron man once were
you know i but i do think that like
similar to the west view hex kind of
fading at the end and then the status
quo has been roughly restored by the end
of the movie we might have some of that
going on like the spell ends or
something but i do think that's still
the main mcu i think in the way that
like the west view heck still had some
um
those people were still pissed off and
they felt betrayed i think there's still
going to be some within the mcu some
residual effects that are left over from
everything that happens in no way home
otherwise i think people just feel too
shortchanged if it's all just in a in a
bubble reality that have no consequences
you know
i think they might go with like the
whole christmas carol vibe though it's
just like oh like all that stuff didn't
really happen to ebenezer scrooge but
like it's the journey that forms you um
someone must have changed by the end of
this in order for it to matter right no
story matters unless someone is just
gonna be like peter parker though uh
it's just gonna be peter
yeah i i i think i just wonder like
not all these people are going to be
straight-up villains to peter by the end
of this movie
which are the sinister six gonna be
united in their antagonism toward peter
are any of them gonna join peter's side
uh like are our doc ock and green goblin
going to be constant threats to peter
for the full two and a half hours
i think it's i no i think specifically
sandman because he's so easily
changeable
uh
he's
they put them in an hourglass and they
kind of just like let them sit there um
oh yeah oh god they're gonna drown on
so but i think he has well if we're
staying to the situation of like
how close he was to his daughter i think
he's someone that's easily able to like
switch sides
that's i that's why i think i'm i'm just
betting now that the first person to
change sides will probably be him all
the sinister six villains had some kind
of relationship with spider-man or peter
parker to where they could flip
um
um like dr connors you know was a mentor
so was otto octavius so was norman
osborne um i would say
of those at least in the rainy films
otto had the least amount of time with
peter parker they just had like that one
lunch date whereas norman osborne it was
like his son's best friend he kind of
grew up uh and then uh dr connors at
least said several classes that peter
parker skipped out on
but that was uh it was different in the
mark webb once right dr connors uh
was more like an auto octavius kind of
science mentor to him
um i would say uh uh
at least
otto uh was kind of controlled by that
neural chip whereas like yeah norman
osborne went full-on crazy
yeah yeah i feel like that one's you're
not gonna be able to change yeah also i
don't want him to change i like him i
have this weird feeling that most of
them will end up like switching to like
not good but like to not wanting to
murder peter because like i know that
there are rumors or something that
sony's planning on making like a
sinister six type of spin-off or
something or like marketing
so i think that you know having them be
evil is not their whole intent for like
at the end of this film i think they
just want to be like oh we're we're like
like suicide squad we got the right ass
people anti-heroes and all that stuff no
i think right norman oscar will probably
be the only one that stays evil
um yeah we will see because i think um
based off of trailer footage the little
we know
like peter is holding on to that cube i
think that's the prison that they're all
contained dr strange is trying to get it
back from him i have a feeling that dr
strange is going to be like i just want
to banish or erase these villains i
think peters believes in rehabilitation
i think he's going to want to try to
like
prove that people can be rehabilitated
like that's his mission in this movie
and he's going to try to turn these guys
good i think there is some external
force that is manipulating doctor
strange he's a big weirdo from
everything i've seen i think that's
going to be the ultimate villain of this
movie is whoever is controlling doctor
strange if it is dr strange if it is
doctor strange i don't know i
i think dr strange is the secret villain
of this because he just wants uh dr
octavius his arms to do surgery again
yes i am the only dog
give her those hands
giving him
like doing magic with extra arms like
that would be nuts there would be just
one yeah there would be the scene of the
portal and then he's going through and
punches himself like
[Laughter]
uh jessica you get the point here for
saying that you would murder peter
parker that's what you want to see i
think that's a rogue tape i don't want
to hold that up
hold up jessica i would murder tom
holland clemens
nope now on the internet now
in the thumbnail this video
let's go with a little thing what's to
murder tom the police knock at my door
they're like we got to talk about this
[Laughter]
he's worried he's afraid uh yeah uh
we're gonna dive into the surprising
casting news that came out this week
regarding an upcoming mcu film but first
grab yourself a cool limited edition
shirt inspired by venom let there be
carnage from our merch partners at epic
hero shop they also have great shirts
for other merch inspired by shang chi
suicide squad and other properties that
we've been loving here in the past few
months find those shirts and all the
great merch options at next
servicemerch.com now guys there's
nothing sexier than confidence and
bluetooth can help give you that
confidence where it counts bluechu has a
unique online service that delivers the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis but in shootable tablets and at a
fraction of the cost you can take them
any time date or night so you can plan
ahead or be ready whenever an
opportunity arises the process is simple
sign up at bluetooth.com consult with
one of their licensed medical providers
and once you're approved you'll receive
your prescription within days and the
best part it's all done online so no
business to the doctor's office no
awkward conversations and no waiting in
line the pharmacy bluetooth tablets are
made in the usa and prepared and shipped
direct to your door in a discrete
package so if you could benefit from
some extra confidence when it's time to
perform bluetooth can help and we've got
a special deal for our audience try
bluetooth free when you use our promo
code rogue at checkout just pay the five
dollars in shipping that's bluetooth.com
promo code rogue to receive your first
month free visit bluetooth.com for more
details and important safety information
and we thank bluetooth for sponsoring
the show also cryptocurrency might feel
like a secret or an exclusive club but
coinbase believes that everyone
everywhere should be able to get in the
door whether you've been trading for
years or just getting started coinbase
can help coinbase offers a trusted and
easy to use platform to buy sell and
spend cryptocurrency they support the
most popular digital currencies on the
market and make them accessible to
everyone they offer portfolio management
protection learning resources and a
mobile app so that you can trade
securely and monitor your crypto all in
one place millions of people in over 100
countries trust coinbase with their
digital assets whether you're looking to
diversify just getting started or
searching for a better way to access
crypto markets start today with coinbase
for a limited time new users can get ten
dollars in free bitcoin when you sign up
today at coinbase.com rogue sign up at
coinbase.com rogue for ten dollars in
free bitcoin this offer is for a limited
time only so be sure to sign up today
that's coinbase.com
rogue and uh you are busy and you have a
lot of things to spend time on one of
them should not be thinking about what
to wear embrace the radically efficient
mac weldon daily wear system the daily
wear system is a selection of clothes
rooted in smart design made with
performance fabrics and built to work
together from breathable t-shirts and
polos to stylish button-ups and shorts
underwear and beyond mac weldon makes it
easy for you to dress for work leisure
or wherever your life takes you here at
new rockstars we are big fans of their
hoodies and sweatpants from their fancy
ace material that's softer than soft
they look as good on the street as they
feel while you are sitting on the couch
they've got groupings of outfits
designed for office workers workout
warriors travel junkies and folks that
just like to lounge you can grab the
pieces that all work together and be
looking great no matter what you are
into buy some time this fall with a
macweldon daily wear system for 20 off
your first order visit macweldon.com
rogue and enter the promo code rogue
that's macweldon.com rogue promo code
rogue for 20 off mac weldon radically
efficient wardrobing all right guys
let's talk about uh this huge news that
came out this week bill murray revealed
in an interview that he will be playing
a small role in am in the wasp quantum
mania but gave no details as to what
that role will be but this third ant-man
movie will feature jonathan majors
returning as kang the conqueror after
his brilliant performance in loki and
introduced catherine newton as cassie
lang aka the young avengers stature and
it seems like it will take place a lot
in the quantum realm maybe the quantum
realm city perhaps chronopolis knowing
that kang is gonna be involved in this
so uh and we also just saw in a video i
explored yesterday the movie's new loopy
title logo and it's based on circles
which means time travel
time travel are we sure so um i wanted
to ask you guys though i had some ideas
about who uh what kind of character bill
murray might be playing who do you think
he's going to be in ant-man three i
think he's gonna be gotta be scott's dad
no i think he's scott lang
oh you think he's older scott lang like
the old man in the suit yes
i think the older scott lang also
because even though he's playing a small
part it has to be important it's bill
murray and i think if we look at loki
how we got richard e grant playing older
loki that was a small part but it was
still a big part and we played a
different version of loki so i think in
this world he's playing a different ver
not a different version older scott lang
and him as scott lang would be very fun
we all love our kooky bill murray and
we'd still get that cookie bill murray
with the years of knowledge that
scotland current like just imagine
scotland older through time doing what
he's doing who is he bill murray
i love that idea yeah
so suck it empty okay
okay i have i have two theories as to
who this could be i think that it's most
likely going to be scott's dad because
we have you know hope's mom and dad in
the picture and hope and scott have been
together for a little while now so they
might be engaged or something maybe they
might be getting married so maybe
scott's dad will be like hey son
i was probably shitty but here i am to
support you i was really shitty i don't
know so i think that scott's dad might
be in the picture in this movie but i
think a more fun guess um because we're
dealing with you know
ant-man and the one of my favorite um
moments in marvel history was when um
hank pym ran into eternity like he grew
so big that he goes into the oververse
or whatever it's called overspace and he
runs it to eternity and i would love if
bill murray was eternity in this in the
mcu that'd be great like that would be
perfect if he was just like hey guys
uh
what are you doing in there it's really
weird uh settled out thank you
i love
i i do love that uh it would be a bummer
though because bill murray said he's not
planning on ever coming back in the mcu
he doesn't really like this genre so if
that'd be like our one shot at getting
eternity in its voice maybe i would like
he's like i'm never coming back yeah
yeah exactly so like based off of uh
some of those those interview quotes i
feel like he's he's not gonna
necessarily be a cameo but maybe he's
going to be a wild whacky character
in i don't know
like
not like a a butler type character but
someone that's the equivalent of like
mobius or something uh-huh in
the quantum realm
and he's going to be really wacky and
really silly either that or he's going
to just make a groundhog day reference
i mean i honestly think that's the tree
we should be barking up angelica because
i bet like bill murray was partially
convinced to be in this movie from
someone showing him clips of loki and
just be like look we got owen wilson
your co-star from all the west anderson
movies like owen wilson's like bill bill
look we can just do what we're doing and
not even have to make any different
acting choices and we can just they they
put all the special effects around us
and you get to just do your thing
and and bill's like okay i guess i'll do
that uh it's really good like imagine
like my idea is like he's just gonna be
this goofball this high priest in
granopolis who's like oh yes i love kang
the conqueror he's yeah he's my lord and
i get to wear these goofy bathrobes and
that's you know uh but i do also love
the idea of him being phil connors of
like he's just collected as this other
character from another reality of like
the ultimate time loop guy you know i i
honestly just want to play for him to
play himself just be like hey it's me
bill murray um like maybe like
baby scott like
imagines bill murray like in the quantum
realm because like i think that in the
quantum realm your mind can make real
reality so maybe he's imagining bill
murray through all of his like quantum
stuff he's like all right it's just like
groundhog day and then bill murray shows
up it's like oh my god i don't know why
i'm here but you imagine me scott and
you imagine me as the old version of me
not the young version of me and
groundhog day yeah i mean that is kind
of like very zombieland random bill
murray cameo right like i don't know if
marvel wanted this to get out clearly
this is just bill murray going rogue
just doing his thing and like talking to
what he thinks is a german newspaper
it's never going to get back to
mainstream press and i bet marvel's and
peyton reed might be like damn it
damn it that was going to be a surprise
cameo
damn it um
but we know it now so get another crazy
cameo on top of that to get us like ipad
i always say that's my video uh yes okay
so a lot of fun ideas out there uh if
you haven't already be sure to watch uh
wednesday's uh
antman three video ain't me in the
mosque mania we got some clues i talk
about a rival
um but i'm gonna give the point to mt
because i like this idea of eternity i
just hope that um
they would be able to get him back for
future cameos disease i know hey he
could just phone it in he could just be
like hey just say these lines
whatever
whatever you want whatever you want um
all right so we're now going to move
into our rouge question are you guys
ready
i think so always yes i'll ever be
um all right guys so here's uh the
question doctor strange in the
multiverse of menace has finished its
principle photography however it has
been confirmed by benedict cumberbatch
that some additional reshoots are
happening later this year and this is
already after
we they already did some reshoots so
we're getting another round of reshoots
we don't have any reason to be concerned
uh as we have learned on every marvel
movie they do reshoots the same story
comes up every time oh my god they're
doing reshoots so is there's trouble in
paradise no they do research and
multiple rounds of reshoots on all of
these movies it's just what every
director wishes he or she could do if
they had the opportunity to go back and
change some stuff and get some better
takes um but since this is the
multiverse of madness i want you guys to
look at some other crazy pop cultural
event that has happened in recent months
uh you know since they've already been
tinkering away at multiverse of madness
what new thing has happened in the
zeitgeist that uh sam raimi's like i
gotta get this in the movie so i'm gonna
reshoot it and force this cameo that
it's no business being in a marvel movie
into this movie go rogue my babies
they're throwing in a baby yoda for sure
uh there's gonna be at least one one
baby yeah
several baby yo die maybe who knows yeah
they wanted to include steve from blues
clues coming back
telling us that he's proud of dr strange
dr strange shed one single tear it's a
whole new scene hey you may have
forgotten me dr strange but i'm proud of
you you've come so i was like look at
you go doctor strange before you go
just cries well i think it'd be fun if
they reshoot it to add like wong or
someone getting ready for halloween and
it's a bunch of squid game outfits
instead of what they were doing before
instead of making them like oh you're
going joseph is like a marvel character
he's like no i need to reshoot it squid
game's really big
and he's just wearing nike okay you know
what that would be hilarious because
like of the tentacle creatures the
interdimensional tentacle creatures so
like they just put a squid game
reference because the squids the squid
game is
going uh a red light green light just
once an emergency happen and they show
up in the nike track suit instead of the
outfit they're supposed to be in i love
that so much because he's an eyeball
it's like
just a knife
red light green light it's so funny it
just kills off people on the uh i was
going to sing the song but i don't think
i'm allowed to sing that song
i don't know the korean words i don't
want to butcher it and just be an
[ __ ] yeah i'm not going to do it
um well i think the point there's got to
go to angelica trey i love this idea of
steve from blue's clues oh my god
coming into this i think that'd be so
sweet and so beautiful and i love that
same rainbows like i gotta get them in
there um well that means all of us are
winners today
good job everybody that's it for this
episode of rogue theory a big thanks to
all of our guests jessica clements
angelica trey and mt uh follow all of
them on social media and support their
many endeavors and can support our
channel by checking out all of our great
merch options at new rockstarsmerch.com
you can follow me at ea boss follow me
rockstars on all social platforms be
sure to subscribe to our channel here on
youtube see you all next week
chubbers
[Music]
you